We're going to calculate the blast radius of an atomic bomb, fortunately,
without dropping any atomic bombs, cause that's one way to do it.
And that was exactly how the U S military were doing this 1940s Manhattan
project, Los Alamos, all of that part of history,
interesting things happening in the physics and math world,
the U S military were doing all these experiments and we're making measurements
of as they changed the size of the bomb or certain weather conditions
as to how fast that sort of mushroom cloud would expand, of course,
quite useful information. If you're dropping a bomb, you know,
potentially near your own soldiers,
or there are certain areas you want to avoid,
you want to have an idea how much that's going to spread out pretty important
information. And as because of the atomic bombs were so new back in the 1940s,
we didn't really know this.
So it did require this like trial and error approach or it required the
clever mathematical approach. And so this is the story of GIA Taylor,
a British mathematician,
who was asked by the UK government to help out during the world war.
So he actually helped home world war one and world war two in world war II.
He was sent over as part of the British delegation to go and visit the test
site, visit the Manhattan project. And he actually saw the first ever blast.
The Trinity test in 1945, he actually witnessed one of,
I think there are only 10 people that were there.
And one of them was this mathematician, GIA Taylor,
what he did using some photographs taken from the explosion was actually
calculate the formula for the blast radius of the atomic bomb,
which at the time was a us military secret.
So da Taylor did these calculations or just published this in mathematical
research journals.
And it was quoted as pretty embarrassing for the U S military at the time,
because this was like the most closely guarded military secrets about the inner
workings of an atomic bomb.
And then the spiritual annotation comes along and just kind of, you know,
does a pretty straightforward calculation as we'll see,
to just get the answers basically. So it's a very,
very cool story and also uses possibly my favorite
tool in all of applied maths, which is that of scaling analysis.
It's very, very applied.
Maths should stress this because you kind of go into physics and think about
what is happening in a problem to them,
write down the important parameters in your problem,
and then combine them in such a way to get the answer you want. So you,
so you do have to have that sort of, uh, very applied physicists,
like mind to be able to use this,
but it's such a good tool because you can calculate the formula for atomic
bomb without setting off a single atomic bomb. And so the way Taylor did it,
first of all,
what factors are going to influence the spreading rate of
our bomb blast? First thing,
at least that came to my mind and to Taylor's mind was the energy.
You have a bigger bomb,
it's going to blow up more stuff it's reasonably straightforward to see.
So we don't know whether that relationship is or anything yet,
but we know that the energy of the bomb is going to affect that blast radius.
So we're going to write down energy. We're going to label.
That's definitely one of the parameters it's going to be an AR problem. Now,
the other one that's reasonably obvious is time. If you just set your bum off,
it's not gone very far. If you wait a few seconds, it's gone a lot further.
We're trying to work out the radius of the blast. So as time increases,
the radius will certainly increase. So we're going to have time,
which we label with a T and now the sort of real fluid
dynamics and physics comes into it.
And Taylor was a fluid dynamicist in Cambridge.
And this is where this really helped him because he thought about the problem as
follows. You have as the bomb detonates,
you have a huge amount of energy being released from a tiny,
tiny volume. And so you have a very,
almost instantaneous explosion from tiny,
tiny volume to massive amount of energy.
And what that's going to do is create a massive,
massively high pressure within that explosion, that sort of cloud of your bomb.
So you can kind of think of it as if this is a sort of initial explosion
in here. If you take this to be pressure,
this is really high inside this region.
And as soon as you get out of the bond region,
the atmospheric pressure is really low. And you almost have like a,
what we would call a shock.
This is where the term shockwave comes from the shockwave of a blast because
here you've got super high pressure from this giant explosion.
And here you've just got atmospheric pressure.
And these are like orders of magnitude different.
What this tells you is not what is important in the problem,
but what is not important. And this is the sort of the fluid dynamics,
the physical intuition of, of these problems. And Taylor was a fluid.
Dynamicist the way he knew this.
So because this is so high and this is so small,
the pressure of the air is not going to play a role in
the expansion of the bomb.
So whether it's high pressure or low pressure weather system,
it's not actually going to matter. So it tells you the pressure is crossed off.
If the air pressure isn't important, then you think, well,
what are the properties of the air are going to affect the spread of the ball?
You would expect that to be a difference in the spreading rate,
depending on the fluid or the air that you're moving through.
The other possibilities are density and maybe temperature.
We have an equation releasing these two, it's called the ideal gas law.
And you often will model air as such. And it says that these two,
if the pressure is constant or negligible, these two just depend on each other.
So he just picked density.
So this sort of physical intuition told you pressure didn't
matter. And that meant it had to be density.
That was the key insight that came from Taylor, being a fluid dynamic.
The pressure of the, this atmosphere doesn't matter if it doesn't,
this pressure matters.
This pressure will absolutely matter,
but this will basically be controlled by the energy.
This is the thing with scaling analysis.
And it's a very good question because there are so many different things you can
pack.
And sometimes it is like black magic that you pick the right ones and put them
together in such a way. So I'm sure there are many,
many examples of scaling analysis not working,
but this just happens to be like possibly my favorite example of it working and
discovering a military secret. So we've got energy, we've got time.
And then we've got density density of the outside air,
which we labeled with RO the scaling analysis is what comes in here because what
you do is you look at the units of your three parameters.
We denote this sort of square bracket in maths. So let's start with time.
Cause that's easy. The units of time are time, seconds,
and I'm going to just call it a time, which is a T now energy.
The way I remember the units of energy is to think of let's take my favorite
energy kinetic energy.
So kinetic energy is half times mass times velocity squared.
So the units are a mass times.
Velocity squared velocity is distance divided by time.
So that's distance over time squared.
So I now have a mask, uh,
length squared over a time squared for the units for energy.
I've got just a T for time and density is a mass per length
cubed because we're working in 3d kilograms per meter cube, for example.
So we've now got the units of energy,
the units of time and the units of density.
And now the scaling analysis argument is to say, well,
I have determined through knowledge of physics and fluid dynamics as Taylor did
that.
These three are the most important parameters that I think control the blast
radius. So if I can arrange these in such a way,
the Tai get rid of the mass and get rid of time from the units and all
I'm left with is a length.
That must be the radius because what other possible length could it be?
That's the kind of argument.
And then of course you have to validate this and test this with some amount of
experiments. So you don't need to do hundreds like the U S military,
but Taylor happened to have one or two photographs from that one test he went to
and he checked it against that and, and showed that it was correct.
So what we just have to do now is combine the three sets of units in such a way
that we just get linked. You got a mass, a length and a time.
So I think if we start by removing mass,
so if we do energy E divided by density row,
then that is equal to square brackets for units,
M L squared over T squared divided by the density,
puts an M on the bottom and an L cubed on top. So the AMS cancel.
And so this is equal to L to the five over T squared.
So now we've got rid of mass, which is very good, but we still have time.
So we get rid of time by introducing T.
So we just are going to have to multiply on the top by time squared.
And that gives us now with the time squared on the top,
we just have L to the five, cause it will cancel. Finally,
this is a length to the power of five. We just want to radius,
which is just owl. So we just take the whole thing to the power of one.
So if we want our time dependent radius of an atomic bomb,
the radius of the atomic bomb is proportional to the energy
to the one fifth,
the time after explosion to the two fifths and the air
density to the minus one fifth.
And that right there was the most closely guarded secret in U S
military in the 1940s.
Had the U S military figured it out with mathematics or had they just used a
number of tests and sort of, you know, guests.
Roughly. So, so if you were doing this experimentally, which is what they did,
you would do lots of different explosions and you would take measurements at
different times as the thing is exploding and expanding. You'd make, take,
do it on different days with different ad densities and you'd use different
sized bombs and you'd have all these data points.
And then you do sort of try and find a scaling that makes the data collapse
into a straight line. That's generally how you do applied maths research today.
That's how I did my experiments during my research, in fact,
so you just get lots of data points and try and plug it all together and then
sort of it's kind of trial and error.
And as suddenly it perfectly fits this pattern.
And Taylor was able to check, he got it, right?
Because he had a few pictures from the Trinity test, isn't it?
Yes, he did. He had these two pictures.
He actually published them in a magazine. And when he released this, this paper,
he published these two images. Um, and so he using, um,
he could check this against, against these actual images to check the radius.
And of course, what we are missing here is there's going to be a constant here.
So this is proportional to so the units match up,
but you can still have a number in this gap.
And now that's the kind of thing you need to do experiments to get and tell you
that I only had the one to compare to.
And so I think he was trying to estimate the size of the bomb dropped in this
Trinity test in 1945. And he believed it was 20 kilotons. Sorry.
He believed it was 22 kilotons. And the actual size was 20,
which given the, this that gets pretty good.
Let's be honest given that he didn't have access to highly
classified us military secrets. He was able to get with at a 10% accuracy,
the size of the bomb that was dropped in that first ever nuclear test.
This isn't going to help you build an atomic bomb. This is just,
this is just going to give you an idea of how devastating that could be.
Absolutely.
So this, this would be one of the first things, given some new,
some new weapon or some new even sort of like a new source of energy.
One of the first things you would want to do would be to try it at different
values of energy, different sizes, different densities,
and see what happens so that before you were able to actually use it safely.
Well, I guess the bombs are really safe in a controlled way. Thank you.
Without unintended circumstances,
you would need to know this kind of information. So this was, as he said,
this was literally done based on the first ever detonation of an atomic bomb.
Is this constant,
this no number here dependent on the type of bomb or would a T and T be
different to an atomic bomb?
I believe so. That's the sort of the limitation of the scaling analysis.
Whilst you can get,
which parameters are important and the powers of those parameters,
you can never get that constant.
But once you've got the constant, it works for all the time.
It bombs. Yeah. There's going to be some error,
absolutely going to be some error, but yes, once you have that constant,
it hopefully would hold for, for a particular,
at least a particular type of atomic bomb.
You've had the same bomb and you dropped it and then you doubled your energy.
This would predict how much more the radius would be and you would absolutely
expect that to follow. What does it tell us? Well,
time is certainly increasing the most, in the sense of it has the highest power.
If time doubles versus energy, double or density doubling,
you're going to see that the biggest change being a tight.
But what it does tells is as you increase the energy, the radius will increase.
But it's also telling you here, if you were to go from eater East squared,
you're only going to get quite a small increase in your radius.
So this one fifth is sort of saying that you really have to ramp up the
energy to get that large radius where, you know,
compared to this being a larger power,
because it's quite a small power and it's, and because the density is negative,
that's on the denominator. So as the density gets higher,
the radius decreases and that's always a good sanity check for these things.
Making sense. If the energy goes up, you expect a bigger bomb.
If you wait longer, you expect a bigger radius.
And if you increase the density of the app,
do you imagine there's more water in the air? It's like thicker,
it's harder for the explosion to move through thicker air,
so you would expect it to shrink. So there's always that nice. As I said,
a sanity check that it does make physical sense and mathematically the units
balance, the scaling works, and then you would then need to do some expert,
at least one experiment to get a grasp on that number.
But for the U S or the way you would think about it is the density of the air
is reasonably constant. So you're dropping the bomb in New Mexico.
The density in the summer will be approximately the same across the summer
period. So you know that the time that just will constantly increase.
So the question would then be say,
you wanted a bomb search that within two seconds of it being dropped,
it had destroyed a one kilometer radius area.
You then plug in one kilometer as your radius. You say,
I want within two seconds it to be gone. I plugged in my ad density.
It tells you the size of the bomb. You have to drop to do that damage. So,
so that's, those really is quite valuable information.
If you're trying to do it like a controlled sort of targeted bomb.
Releasing, and it produces two neutrons,
each of which go on to react or to split other
atoms of plutonium. So you'll get to chain reaction, hand,
the explosion just builds up and up and up.
[inaudible].